so another weekend goes by and more
serious questions about the stability of
President Trump over the weekend Donald
Trump used some horrible dog whistles
about mostly black Baltimore being
infested and of course people reacted to
that and we'll discuss that separately
and I I'm thinking my take on it may be
a little different than much of what has
been around over the last couple of days
but once again in the big picture Donald
Trump is reacting extraordinarily
erratically to the growing reality that
the congressional push for impeachment
has been reinvigorated a judge has now
been asked to release grand jury
evidence from Robert Moeller's
investigation more than 100 Democrats in
the House now supports an impeachment
inquiry against Donald Trump which I am
also going to talk about later and
Donald Trump went on a nearly 24-hour
tweet storm completely unhinged we've
seen to our Twitter storms we've seen
even like 10 or 12 hour ones if I recall
correctly but this was something new
altogether now can anybody take the
phone away from Donald Trump it doesn't
seem like that's the case can anybody
talk sense into Donald Trump about these
tweets no I don't know that it's
necessarily seen as a problem because
even though these tweets that I'm about
to show you exposed that we have an
unstable president are dozens of tweets
where social media has now become the
equivalent for Donald Trump of a guy
ranting in the subway while urinating
under the stairs I am going to make the
case that actually these tweets serve a
purpose for Donald Trump aside from the
content which is to continue setting the
agenda and the narrative at the
exclusion of other topics and I'm gonna
get to that in a little bit so let's get
to some of the tweets that Donald Trump
sent out this is just a sampling Donald
Trump starting with from the bottom up
in chronological order congressman
Elijah Cummings has been a brutal bully
shouting and screaming at the great men
and women of border patrol about
conditions at the southern border when
actually his Baltimore district is far
worse and more dangerous his district is
considered the worst in the USA has
proven last week during a congressional
tour the border is clean efficient and
well-run
very crowded Cummings district is a
disgusting rat and rodent infested mess
if he spent more time in Baltimore maybe
he could help clean up this very
dangerous and filthy place why is so
much money sent to the Elijah Cummings
district when it is considered the worst
run and most dangerous anywhere in the
United States no human being would want
to live there where is all this money
going how much is stolen investigate
this corrupt mess immediately and then
continuing consideration is being given
to declaring an Tifa the gutless radical
left whack jobs who go around hitting
only non fighters people over the heads
with baseball bats a major organization
of terror along with ms-13 and others
would make it easier for police to do
their jobs going on the Democrats were
trying mightily to revive the badly and
irrevocably tarnished witch-hunt hoax
until robert muller put on the greatest
display of an aptitude and incompetence
that the halls of congress has ever seen
continuing the Dems are now coming out
of shock from the terrible molar
performance and are starting to spin
impeachment all over again how sick and
disgusting and bad for our country such
a big victory for our country supreme
court approves trump administration plan
to use military funds for the wall
skipping over a few you'll see that
donald trump continued this rant saying
we gave Nadler and his trump hating Dems
the complete molar report we didn't have
to and even Muller himself but now that
both were a total bust they say it
wasn't good enough nothing will ever be
good enough for them witch hunt no
collusion no obstruction total
exoneration Democrat witch-hunt
then he retweeted a bunch of Fox News
videos and continued tweeting about
various quotes regarding Robert molars
testimony talking again about
congressman Elijah Cummings who's been
able to do so little for the people of
Baltimore
statistically Baltimore ranks last in
almost every major category cummins as
does
Cummings has done not nothing but milk
Baltimore dry but the public is getting
wise to the bad job that he's doing and
then going into conspiracies the real
collusion the conspiracy the
I'm was between the Clinton campaign the
DNC fusion GPS Christopher Steele and
many others including Comey McCabe Lisa
Paige and her lover or and his wonderful
and then he continues to go on with that
getting into more conspiracies about the
Democrats are doing the Russians dirty
work and on and on and on in truly
stunning fashion and then lastly quoting
random people from Fox and friends
including you'll notice at the top of
your screen Pete hagseth who said Elijah
Cummings has had his chance to address
it crime and conditions in Baltimore for
decades and he hasn't gotten it done so
endless I mean and a total of nearly
thirty tweets this is the President of
the United States aside from the content
of his tweets which is insane aside from
the amount of time that he's spending
tweeting the level of rage that this man
is exhibiting towards just everyone is a
sign that Donald Trump is very worried
if and when Donald Trump's finances
really start to be dug into by Democrats
in the House and we're getting very
close to that I believe that Donald
Trump is going to go to the neck to the
next level this is a level which we
still have not seen and to be very clear
this is going to be a level where all
bets are off
I mean it's Trump going to start
actually calling people the n-word I
don't know he might he just might I
don't know whether Trump has the
restraint not to do almost anything that
we might imagine if and when it gets to
that point now there is another
hypothesis that I was reading about
which might explain these extended tweet
storms by Donald Trump it may be that
the legal staff either personal lawyers
or White House lawyers have started to
tell Trump listen there's a chance you
get indicted if you don't get reelected
in 2020 I don't know how they'd couch it
I don't know what language they would
use to explain this to Donald Trump it's
all still very speculative but it is not
outside the realm of possibility that
Donald Trump is starting to be warned by
his own legal team internally about
listen
Moeller is right by the letter of the
law you can be indicted after leaving
the White House winning in 2020 would be
a sort of insurance policy he likes to
use that term but it would be an
insurance policy for him against
possible indictment if you think Donald
Trump is losing it now tweeting 30 times
in 20 18 hours or something like that
just remember that between now and 2020
there are any number of things that
could happen that will drastically
escalate Donald Trump beyond what we've
already seen and for his sake you'd
think someone on his staff would work to
take away Twitter access but it's maybe
easier said than done as we've known as
we've reported before and as we've we've
known based on a number of different
reports Trump will not even turn his
phone over for a security screening by
intelligence agencies 2020 Trump is a
trump that will be running believing
that it may take a win in 2020 to keep
him potentially out of prison okay that
is going to be a far crazier Trump than
we have ever seen and now I want to
focus in a little more specifically on
the Baltimore tweets there was a
fascinating moment on propaganda Network
Fox News over the weekend if you've
watched this program before and if you
haven't in your on our youtube channel
for the first time please make sure you
are subscribing to the channel we're
trying to get to 1 million subscribers
but if you've watched before you know
that sometimes Shepard Smith or Chris
Wallace will make at least like a little
sense on Fox News and they'll cut short
or short-circuit some obvious lie here
or there and it's a good thing when they
do it and I have an example for you
today but this is more than just sort of
conflict porn which is what a lot of
corporate media likes to do here's what
I want you to understand about what I'm
gonna play for you today the Trump
administration and the people around
Trump are telling lies all the time
about just basic knowable facts these
are not lies hidden in political
rhetoric or selective statistics these
are just straight-up demonstrable lies
and in the clip I'm going to play for
you today Donald Trump's chief of staff
Mick Mulvaney went on Fox News Sunday he
was interviewed by Fox's Chris Wallace
and
Mulvaney tried to assert he claimed that
Muller's testimony effectively is an
exoneration of donald trump remember
they've been claiming that molars report
is an exoneration of donald trump which
it's not and now they are claiming that
robert molars testimony is an
exoneration of donald trump which it's
not and they get into a back-and-forth
about
Omo ler said there was no way Trump was
getting indicted no matter what for what
he did this is an exoneration de facto
and in a lot of places Donald Trump's
cronies the people around him the
brown-nosing sycophants as I like to
call them they've been getting away with
this stuff and even on Fox News they
usually get away with these types of
lies it goes unchallenged and then it
becomes part of the de facto status quo
narrative this is how propaganda works
Fox News doesn't have to perpetuate the
propaganda themselves even though they
do in many cases they can simply stand
aside while the Trump administration
creates it this is why I believe in
responsible platforming this is why when
I interview an extremist like whoever as
many many times have done before I don't
have to agree with what they say I can
make the problem worse merely by
standing aside and letting them say
their thing which is why I don't do that
when I do interviews with radicals and
extremists that's why this is so
important this is a small victory that
chris wallace short-circuits this let's
take a look at the video muller answered
the single one outstanding question he
said what they asked him would you have
indicted the president if he were not
the president and and Muller said
absolutely not he would not do that he
answered and no that's not what he said
he'd you know that isn't what he said he
said we didn't because of the OLC the
Office of Legal Counsel guidelines he
said we could we didn't even make a
decision he got asked the question by
congressman Liu who I know said would
you indicted him if he were not the
president and the ad said yes we would
have been he went back to the beginning
of the second hearing an alien and
that's when he said we couldn't
he said we yes he did I agree but what
he said was that we I would I wouldn't
have made it we didn't even make that
decision because the guidelines
prevented us from doing that I actually
just think you're wrong on that if they
could record will show what it shows if
they have to promise
so Mulvaney wants to parrot this idea
that molar vindicated Donald Trump even
though the opposite was actually said at
the hearings so let's look at the
transcript a Jerry Nadler during the
hearing said so the report did not
conclude that he did not commit
obstruction of justice is that correct
Muller says that is correct and Nadler
adds and what about total exoneration
did you actually totally exonerate the
president relevant because that's what
Trump has been claiming Moeller says no
Nadler adds now in fact your report
expressly states that it does not
exonerate the president and molar
confirms it does - which Nadler adds and
your investigation actually found quote
multiple acts by the president that were
capable of exerting undue influence over
law enforcement investigations including
the Russian interference and obstruction
investigations is that correct - which
Muller says correct this is why we have
to interrupt the echo chamber at any
point where we have an opportunity to do
that because this is how propaganda
spreads nah when we talk about Donald
Trump and the way in which he uses
Twitter a lot of his Twitter use a more
interesting analysis of his Twitter use
I will say is not about the content of
each tweet per se but about the way in
which Donald Trump will use Twitter to
start tweeting the exact same stuff that
his chief of staff will go on Fox News
and say and that then some right-wing
activist a commentator will do a blog
post about and Donald from jr. will
retweet this is how they foam at that
echo echo chamber the way that the
propaganda machine works is obfuscate
and mischaracterize as much as you can I
call that line you could use those
softer terms obfuscate and miss
character characterize if you want in
order to make the truth very difficult
to even find because you're wading
through all sorts of conflicting
statements then once you've inserted
your narrative into the broader
discussion which is there's nothing to
see here
you start to misdirect and distract with
things like Baltimore is infested as an
example and then in other cases you
simply say nothing altogether you go
totally silent as if the issue not exist
doesn't exist which is actually a really
effective way to short-circuit the media
narrative because if media can't get
people to react to something it becomes
very difficult to continue that story on
and on and on that's the broader way in
which the propaganda model works and
Chris Wallace I mean listen I'm not
gonna go around telling you Chris
Wallace is the best person around but to
the extent that he at least
short-circuited this one minor element
of Donald Trump's cronies trying to
spread propaganda lies I think better
said we should commend him for it
make sure that you are following the
David Pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show and while you're there
follow me as well at David Pakman
I finally got finally I've got a tomato
plant I've been monitoring and watering
and pruning for three months and I
finally got some Tomatoes there's a
picture on my Instagram go check it out
David Pakman right back after this
something truly stunning and disgusting
happened last night and I'm disgusted by
it I'm I'm having trouble even putting
my thoughts together because it is so
vile and disgusting
last night I was planning to stream live
commentary on the CNN debate the first
night of it as I always do I started the
stream 15 minutes before the event at
the time that the debate itself started
our channel had 10,000 live viewers and
climbing very very quickly lots of
people wanted to watch my commentary on
the debate participate in the live shows
that we do around big political events
at two minutes past the hour 802 p.m.
Eastern
CNN shut us down and they shut us down
hard
issuing what's called a hard copyright
strike to our YouTube channel in
addition to ending the stream on the
screen for you now is the takedown
notice you will notice at the bottom
left that it says manually detected this
means it was not an algorithm that
caught us inadvertently as someone
stealing their content but this was a
person whose name I've blurred out who
personally at CNN found our stream and
went out of their way to get us a
copyright strike you will notice in the
lower right of the screen it says strike
expires October 28 2019
this means we are banned from all live
streaming on YouTube for 90 days this is
a disaster and this was optional okay
there's a mechanism for CNN to just take
the ad revenue from our stream but not
shut it down this is what NBC was doing
the last debate two channels of our size
that are not stealing content we have
established audiences this is fair use
audiences want to hear our commentary
and we are providing something of value
we are not just repeating a stream and
adding nothing CNN could have chosen to
put a third party claim on our video and
allow the stream to continue but they
take the ad revenue and I would have
been fine for that people support our
streams with super chats and memberships
and the like but instead they do this
they choose to jeopardize our account
for three months and then if you think
this is just okay not that crazy then it
gets even more disgusting the vice
president and spokesperson for CNN
worldwide attacked me on Twitter
implying that we are some kind of
fraudulent pirating operation take a
look at this insanity tweeting of course
you can't pirate content we spent
millions and millions to produce and the
irony of this is amazing first of all
you spent millions and millions to
produce one event that tells you the
scale and size of your operation why do
you care about an independent channel
like mine doing live coverage about your
event if this is the scale at which
you're operating which it is how does
what I'm doing even rank high enough to
number one trigger somebody to manually
seek me out and shut me down and number
two why are you even tweeting at me
you're the vice-president of a
department of CNN and of course using
the word pirating is so dismissive like
I get it I'm not CNN but this is a show
that's in YouTube's 1 or 2 top percent
were professionally produced we have an
audience of tens of thousands of people
who are waiting for my analysis pirating
impe lines implies I'm a guy in a
basement rebroadcasting a feed of the
debate alone not creating programming
with live callers and analysis and
something of value and then other CNN
flunkies jump right in liking this guy's
tweets a Hong kong-based CNN
journalist CNN's communications director
just loving loving how CNN is treating
us and this part is maybe the craziest
okay I don't know if it relates to this
copyright strike you might have noticed
that on YouTube we've had this join
button where you can become a YouTube
member for a few bucks a month we had
gotten up to almost a thousand of those
YouTube members this morning all
thousand of those are gone I don't know
if it's a glitch I've contacted YouTube
I've told them listen we got a copyright
strike I looked at our member list on
YouTube and it went from almost a
thousand to zero is this a glitch or
have we really lost the thousand members
on YouTube we spent a year building up
so this is bad
sadly they basically won my tools for
fighting this are very limited we've
submitted a counterclaim which takes ten
business days to be reviewed by YouTube
and then after two weeks of that they
send it to CNN and CNN has another month
and they can simply reject my
counterclaim I've contacted my YouTube
rep I've contacted the YouTube Twitter
account so far no dice so this is very
very bad for us live streams generate
revenue for us we were planning on doing
maybe half a dozen major ones in the
next three months around debates and
other political events one bit of
success I did go over to twitch last
night I did my first stream on Twitch
and it went pretty well so first and
foremost follow us on Twitter at
twitch.tv/ludendi
don't let them win okay they take their
millions and millions like this guy told
me and they use it to shut down people
like me I hope that you will support us
directly I'm asking for you to do that
you can get a membership on our web site
at join pakman.com takes under a minute
really supports the work that we're
doing helps us fight this type of stuff
or you can throw us a pledge of as
little as $1 a month on patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show it's
bad out there it's bad make sure you're
following me on twitch at twitch.tv
slash David Pakman hope to see you there
tonight
what a night last night I don't even
know really where to start
certainly going to talk about the drama
we were involved in with CNN because of
last night's debate but before I get to
that let's just talk about the debate
itself I am going to say things that
might shock you about Marianne
Williamson performance last night given
what I said about her a couple of weeks
ago but before we get to that we were
wondering in terms of the debate in
general night one debate to last night
would Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren together be bad for the
progressive wing of the Democratic Party
or would it be good my thought was that
it would be good and indeed it was very
very very good Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders last night completely
dominated the first night of the second
presidential debate they did a
stunningly good job of making it clear
that they are not the radicals their
ideas are not the ideas outside of the
mainstream and that opposing their ideas
is increasingly what's radical which was
exactly my hope my idea was when I had a
video answer I did a question about this
last week my idea was that having both
of them up on the stage together rather
than each as the lone sort of strong
progressive on two different stages that
having them together would create the
idea that there is this very strong well
thought out of mature contingent of the
Democratic primary that is adults in the
room with serious well thought out ways
to accomplish the more progressive ideas
that have been mainstreamed over the
last couple of years which includes
health care inequality taxation the
military tuition free college or college
paid for through taxation and both of
them on the stage together did exactly
that Warren and Bernie had number one a
strong coalition of the progressive part
of the Democratic Party and number two
they had a bunch of what I call debate
kill shots and I hate that this is how
debates are evaluated but both of them
had good ones the format of these
debates
sadly doesn't allow
for depth because there's too many
candidates the answers are too short and
the topics are too wide in one evening
to really go in depth there should be
the ideal thing would be five candidates
for an hour and a half just on economics
five candidates for an hour and a half
just on foreign policy it's not what we
had so you've got to look at who had
these kill shots and both Bernie and
Warren came prepared and their biggest
victory was making the point that their
ideas should be the norm not the
exception let's look at a few of these
moments one such moment was when John
Delaney started playing the role of the
enlightened pragmatist who isn't going
to fall for the unrealistic ideas of
Elizabeth Warren or Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren shut it down take a
look so I think when we run on real
solutions not impossible promises when
we run on things that are workable not
fairytale economics you know I don't
understand why anybody goes to all the
trouble of running for president of the
United States just to talk about what we
really can't do and shouldn't fight for
another instance Bernie Sanders straight
up telling Jake Tapper your question is
a right wing talking point which sadly
was too common last night I'm gonna
delve more into that this was just a
very good move by Bernie Jake Tapper
asking candidates if they're in favor of
increasing taxes on the middle class to
pay for Medicare for all and Bernie said
Jake that's a Republican talking point
and by the way for-profit health care
companies are advertising on CNN right
now Jake your question is a Republican
talking point at the end of the day by
the way and by the way by the way the
health care industry will be advertising
tonight on this program you Center
senator Warren it's your turn Oh
[Applause]
tonight with that talking point senator
Warren Elizabeth Warren said in no
uncertain terms that white supremacy has
to be called domestic terrorism yes this
is fantastic I've been saying this for
years and it should be called domestic
terrorism and there were a lot of zeros
and ones on yesterday's debate stage who
were desperate because they know this is
their last shot to make it into the
third debate in early September in the
middle of September they need at least
2% in four different polls plus a
hundred and thirty thousand total donors
with no fewer than 400 donors from each
of 20 states so a lot of these zeros and
ones went in thinking I'm just gonna
pick a fight with anybody I can pick a
fight with Delaney with Warren was one
example here's Tim Ryan trying to get
one over on Bernie Sanders on Medicare
for all and Bernie doesn't have a second
of it he shuts it right down those
things they will be better because
Medicare for all is comprehensive it
covers all healthcare needs for senior
citizens it will finally include dental
care hearing aids and eyeglasses but you
don't second of all
boom Bernie also by the way like Warren
calling out the people who say we can't
do all of this stuff take a look at that
I get a little bit tired of Democrats
afraid of big ideas Republicans are not
afraid of big ideas they could give a
trillion dollars in tax breaks to
billionaires and profitable corporations
they could bail out the crooks on Wall
Street so please don't tell me that we
cannot take on the fossil fuel industry
and nothing happens unless we go guys
the theme here was number one Bernie
plus Warren clearly developing the soul
sort of elder statesman progressive wing
status within this Democratic primary
that's a really good thing showing the
strength of the progressive movement and
of progressive ideas making those who
oppose their ideas look quite frankly
very uninformed and very ignorant
another theme was sadly
terrible moderation Bernie called out
that one question as a Republican
talking point there were actually many
of these questions when they were
talking about paying for college through
taxes some candidates want to pay for
two years associate's degree like I
think Beto O'Rourke some candidates want
to do for years but tuition only whereas
other candidates have the idea of more
comprehensive room and board and books
and fees even which are quite high being
covered through taxation but invariably
this thing comes up about if there's
free college for everyone you're also
paying for free college for rich kids
who we don't need to be paying for some
of the Dems sort of agreed with that
actually I think Amy Klobuchar going
from memory didn't immediately shut down
that concern as she should have this is
a silly distraction and it's the fault
of the moderators and to some degree the
Democratic candidates could have done a
better job of exposing the question is
problematic this was in yesterday I did
my twenty twenty anti playbook for
Democrats what not to do if you're
trying to defeat Donald Trump don't get
involved in losing debates every social
welfare program has some free riders
either people who don't really need the
benefit but are getting it anyway and or
people who are lying in order to get a
benefit they shouldn't actually qualify
for in this particular case with quote
free college but what we really mean is
college paid for through tax revenues
that are connected the very rich kids
are likely not even interested in going
to the state schools that would be
tuition free under these plans we're
talking about a tiny fraction of the
money that such a plan would cost we
don't need to worry about it that's just
the reality Harvard and Yale aren't
covered by these plans we're talking
about state public colleges and
universities it is a distraction from
the huge stimulative effect and a huge
value that would come from people not
coming out of college in crazy student
loan debt if you come out of college and
crazy student loan debt you are paying
interest to banksters that's not
economically stimulative if
you come out of college without student
loan debt yes college may have been paid
for partially or fully through taxation
you are immediately taking your wages
and contributing them back into the
economy not to banksters but to local
businesses and in ways that are actually
economically stimulative instead of
interest paid to big banks so that was
just again the the framing of the debate
completely wrong now I also have to
drastically change my view about
Marianne Williamson and I know that some
people are worried about that because
they're like no no no your view last
week was the right one
Marianne Williamson is very quirky she
has no shot she has the background as a
New Age guru which I am NOT a fan of but
she actually did really well last night
because she stayed away mostly from her
woowoo New Age stuff Bernie and Warren
definitely won the debate we could argue
about who did better than the other
could go either way but Marianne
Williamson performance was clearly the
third-place performance he or she is
Wacka Lee talking about a dark psychic
force but she actually sounds quite
strong here and gets a good reaction if
you think any of this wall teenis is
going to deal with this dark psychic
force of the collectivized hatred that
this president is bringing up in this
country then I'm afraid that the
Democrats are going to see some very
dark days we need to say it like it is
it's bigger than flint it's all over
this country it's particularly people of
color it's particularly people who do
not have the money to fight back and if
the Democrats don't start saying it then
why would those people feel that they're
there for us and if those people don't
listen she seems to always be on the
edge of claiming that we will solve our
problems by holding crystals but she was
actually quite strong yesterday in her
presentation
she's polling 0.3 percent I don't know
what it's gonna do for her but she at
least put in a good performance and
there was this just general deficit of a
format that really allows deep
conversation and in playing the game
Marianne Williamson did well for herself
that being said she's wacky and people
get mad at me for saying this people ask
me what I mean check out just one
example okay in one of her books she
says sickness is not a sign of God's
judgement but of our judgment on
ourselves we get sick if we judge
ourselves and then she later says in the
same page that sickness is merely an
illusion that doesn't exist her 2010
weight-loss book recommends sage
cleansing your kitchen and praying
yourself thin and she once tweeted God
his big swine flu small see every cell
of your body filled with divine light
pour God's love on our immune systems
truth protects this is insanity it's
insanity but she's funny in the debates
and I liked her presence and the crowd
was reacting positively to her and she
was clearly in third place and I guess I
would say Buddha judge sort of able to
tread water and do okay in some spots I
would say putative Lee in fourth place
although I don't know how much it will
do with him
tent up for him tonight we have Biden
with a bunch of other people I will be
streaming live commentary on twitch at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman I hope you
will follow me there and next I want to
talk about why I will be streaming on
Twitch okay so there has been this
explosion of controversy from Donald
Trump calling the mostly black city of
Baltimore a rodent infested mess that
was somewhere in those 30 or so tweets
that Donald Trump sent the ball to the
population of Baltimore is two-thirds
black a 62 percent black 30% white he's
also talked about Elijah Cummings who is
the black congressman from Maryland so
let's look specifically now at the
Baltimore related tweets once again
Trump tweeting Congress
Elijah Cummings has been a brutal bully
shouting and screaming at the great men
and women of Border Patrol about
conditions at the southern border when
actually his Baltimore district is far
worse and more dangerous his district is
considered the worst in the USA as
proven last week during a congressional
tour the border is clean efficient and
well-run just very crowded Cummings
district is a disgusting rat and rodent
infested mess if he spent more time in
Baltimore maybe he could help clean up
this very dangerous and filthy place so
of course this is being called racist by
lots of people because it is hugely
racially tinged and it's tinged with
some of the same language that white
nationalists used and that anti-semites
and Nazis historically used about Jews
is it demonstrably actually racist I
mean yeah it probably is but I'm going
to make the case to you today that it
actually doesn't matter at this point
debating whether this is racist is a
loser's game in this particular case and
I think the left needs to understand
this going forward Republicans
immediately after Donald Trump was
accused of being racist for criticizing
Baltimore in this way Republicans
immediately pointed to Bernie Sanders
prior comments that Baltimore is a third
world country and a disgrace now the
context was totally different but it
immediately muddies the water did Bernie
mean that it's a third world country
because there's black people so yes this
infested stuff is the same language that
goes back to Nazi terminology about Jews
about Jews as an infestation like
roaches or vermin that needs to be
exterminated it's the same language
there's no doubt about it and of course
immediately the conversation becomes
about well Nancy Pelosi says it is
racist and Trump's talking not about
Baltimore itself or or Elijah Cummings
he's talking about the circumstances in
Baltimore and even Bernie has agreed
he's literally talking about rats he's
not saying black people or as he's
saying there is a big rat problem in
Baltimore and you are actually racist
because you see Trump's comments as
racist you're the problem not us I do
not think that
another public adjudication of if or how
racist Trump's comments are is going to
help our movement remove Donald Trump
now there will be some of the audience
who disagree with me and they will say
we've got to be calling this out I want
to be really clear here I'm not saying
Trump's comments aren't racist they are
hugely racially tinged the languages
language that we've seen among racists
for a very very long time
I'm not saying Trump doesn't have a lot
of racist supporters he obviously does
what I'm thinking out loud about here is
that I don't see the path between
another five days back and forth about
who thinks Trump's comment was racist
and who doesn't I don't see that as
being useful to the goal of removing
Donald Trump in 2020 and blinging
bringing some semblance of sanity back
to the United States because remember I
told you weeks ago this is now a
strategy lots of people are supporting
Trump because of comments like this this
is who they increasingly are publicly
Trump has emboldened them to publicly
say they support this language it's not
a liability for Trump's re-election for
him to use this language if Trump's
public racism isn't a liability then I
don't know what we gain by having these
incidents occupy five days in the media
of a debate over how racist was it at
the exclusion of reporting about all of
the terrible things that Donald Trump
and his administration are actually
doing I believe we are fomenting a
pointless cycle not one that isn't based
on fact
okay I'm not defending the comments for
example though yesterday morning Trump's
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney was on TV
defending Donald Trump's use of the word
infested when there are many more
important things that Mick Mulvaney
should be confronted about so this is
now a secondary news cycle to take
attention away from the immediate crises
that are going on the focus should be
it's beneath the office of the President
to insult cities and to insult members
of Congress and to talk in this way
period meanwhile the border is a human
rights Fiasco Trump has destroyed
alliances all over the world the White
House is now a laughingstock under Trump
we're Americans we don't want to be a
laughingstock around the world and Trump
has failed to deliver basically every
campaign promise his supporters cannot
be reasoned with and therefore a
five-day debate over who thinks the
comments were racist how racist was it
what stupid ways can trump is find to
defend Trump is not going to help us win
in 2020 okay
the constant disarray and reaction to
the content of Trump's tweets lets him
control the story and the narrative
there is a narrative about the tweets
that we need to talk about it's that
they are part of the propaganda model
that allows Donald Trump to control the
discussion that should be our analysis
and I'll be talking about that later on
today if you disagree with my
perspective on this let me know I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show okay we now
have to talk about CNN's role in this
second Democratic primary debate there
is no other way to say it
CNN's production and management of the
presidential debate over the last two
nights was disgusting there's no other
way to say it it was everything that is
wrong with political discourse and with
corporate media I mean is it that they
could have done nothing worse that I can
imagine other than cartoonishly terrible
things that would never really happen
and I'm really talking about everything
the format was a disaster their handling
of the digital rights of the content
itself was an absolute embarrassment
this really was one of the worst
produced debates from start to finish
that I can remember and if this is a
signal about what to expect from now
until the last debate of 2020 democracy
and discourse is in serious trouble
which you probably already knew and it's
hard to know even where to start I told
you yesterday and again in today's
debate wrap up that they tried
desperately to create fake drama not
even hiding the totally base and brazen
ways in which they were just trying to
get candidates to call each other out
and first of all much like with the NBC
debate format that's really the only way
that you can sort of do well as I've
talked about when you have a format
which allows for very short answers even
shorter and sporadic rebuttals sometimes
as short as 15 seconds
all you can do is try to bring these
killshot gotcha moments that is by
design and the format reinforces that
and the moderators regularly trying to
pit the candidates against each other
not in a way that really helps us
explore issues and ideas listen to me
talk about ideas but only in a way that
encourages these attempts at kill shots
additionally the debates were way too
long the first one ran about two hours
and 40 minutes I think the second night
was about two hours and 45 but
understand that on night one
the first question wasn't asked until
twenty three minutes had already gone by
they started with these sports team
introduction like videos they included a
commercial before you even had the first
questions they did introductions very
slowly bringing the candidates out onto
the stage they did opening statements
which tell us nothing and then on the
second night 27 minutes went by before
the first question was even asked the
opening statements should be done away
with the sport suffocation of the
debates should be stopped and it's just
way too long with such little substance
the second night going even longer and
again almost a half hour before you saw
a question
it started at 8:00 you could have tuned
in at 8:30 and have missed only part of
the first question this is an
embarrassment the response windows
obviously too short cutting everyone off
sometimes after even only 15 seconds
anyone who's serious about learning
about the positions of the candidates
could not have possibly done it from
this debate and I know the NBC one
wasn't anything to write home about but
the CNN one was even worse the
moderators were way too much of a
presence almost like they just wanted to
hear themselves talk there are already
too many candidates competing for
airtime and we've got the moderators
also in that competition and then half
the questions were premise taun
Republican talking points for so-called
liberal media which CNN is accused of
being they did a hell of a job of asking
the questions that Republican would have
Republicans would have wanted asked in
the ways that Republicans would have
asked them and then as you know the
digital rights man
at CNN shut down my stream on night one
on YouTube they shut down many other
streams from semi prominent news in
politics youtubers they gave us a
copyright strike jeopardizing our entire
YouTube account commandeering an entire
day of my time yesterday ultimately
getting that strike repealed by the way
which is a good thing and the DNC
shouldn't stand for this the DNC is
complicit and the DNC should be
demanding that whichever Network gets to
brand the debate and produce the debate
they should be forced to allow it for
repurposing as if it were the State of
the Union address on c-span I actually
disagree with debates for public office
even being held by private organizations
but if they are they must be treated
like a public service event we're
picking the next president or at least
the person who will compete to be the
next president
in the general election it can't be a
sporting event for profit at the
exclusion of everybody else it was an
absolute and total embarrassment the
next one is in September ABC News
Univision together are running it I
really hope it's not another disgusting
atrocity like what we saw on CNN the
last two nights but it probably will we
will be let me know what changes you
think would be the most positive that
could be made to the way these debates
have been produced so far I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show so we knew when we
looked at the proposal for Donald
Trump's Republican tax cut last year we
knew from reading it that it would
increase the budget deficit there are
good and bad reasons to deficit spend
we've debated some of those reasons
before what we have almost unanimous
consent on is that deficit spending to
give tax cuts to the richest Americans
is not an economic economically
stimulative reason to go into debt so we
knew it would happen and it has the
deficit has exploded the numbers show it
we've covered it before and so Donald
Trump is now faced with exploding budget
deficits added to his China tariffs
which have so deeply hurt farmers that
the federal government is now paying to
bail them out as well just racking up
even more deficits again as a result of
the policies that Donald Trump has
chosen chosen to enact so what is it
that Republicans had Cruz is doing he's
demanding a tax cut for the rich
expedited without even getting
congressional approval Cruz sent a
letter to Treasury Secretary Stephen
minuchin asking that capital gains be
indexed to inflation now this requires
some explanation and I hope that I'm
gonna do a good job of this because
these things are not always the easiest
to explain to understand how this is a
tax cut for the rich you have to
understand how capital gains normally
work normally imagine that you buy a
thousand dollars worth of shares of
stock and those shares of stock go up in
value to $5,000 the numbers are really
clear you paid a thousand it's worth
worth five thousand when you sell those
shares you have four thousand in gains
and you pay capital gains tax on the
four thousand dollars that's easy now to
index capital gains to inflation means
that you add inflation to the purchase
price of a thousand dollars so in our
example imagine that you paid the
thousand dollars for those shares five
years ago and in those five years
there's been enough inflation that a
thousand dollars then is like a thousand
eighty one dollars today that's what I
got when I used an inflation a
calculator when you index capital gains
to inflation you allow the cost basis of
those shares to be a thousand eighty one
dollars instead of a thousand so what
that means is instead of paying capital
gains taxes on that full four thousand
dollars you're only paying capital gains
on a little bit over thirty nine hundred
dollars now it doesn't sound like much
with those numbers but that's what's
important about this this is a ton of
money for the very rich the reason that
it is effectively a tax cut for the rich
is that for most people indexing capital
gains to inflation is a difference of
just a few dollars here they're 86
percent of this action would go to the
top one percent okay understand the
scope of those numbers 86 percent of the
benefit of May
capital gains indexed to inflation would
go to the top 1% at a cost of more than
100 billion dollars over a decade
meaning even more debt which Donald
Trump told us he was going to eliminate
the mere suggestion that this is an
emergency requiring executive action is
laughable now this is one of those cases
let me be clear I would love this over
time more and more of my income has come
from capital gains of different kinds
this is a change that would be great for
me but it's an immoral change there is
no economically defensible rationale for
doing this at all never mind
the completely comical farcical
assertion that this is such an emergency
that it should be done by executive
order rather than by actually getting a
bill through Congress and signed into
law in order to do this which they
probably wouldn't be able to do because
it is such a capitalist handout the
funniest or maybe the saddest part about
this is that Ted Cruz is actually
touting it as a way to quote help
everyday Americans 86% of the benefit
from this would go to the top one
percent the bottom 99% would then split
14 percent of the benefit and by the way
I think if you looked at like the bottom
90% they would get a small portion of
that 14 percent I assume the lion's
share of that 14 percent would go for
those between the top one percent and
the top 10 percent and meanwhile the
minimum wage hasn't even kept up with
inflation ok understand the sick
hypocrisy and crony bottom-feeding
pond-scum nonsense of this they say
emergency we've got to index capital
gains to inflation meanwhile the minimum
wage hasn't kept up with inflation the
bottom half of America hasn't seen in
real terms wage increase in decades or
what is it 30 or 40 years that's not an
emergency but indexing capital gains to
inflation is such a problem such an
emergency that immediately we need to go
outside of the normal legislative
process and get an executive order in
place these people are amoral
that's it I mean Ted Cruz has to be
voted out but Ted Cruz is just a symptom
of the disease it's way bigger than Ted
Cruz